[Music]  a year of work for a four-minute flight  isn't that something we're all ready if  you are sir well let's go find out if  this  we got a breach in the perimeter  thank you  [Music]  i was like your mission law  after a full year of being marooned on  this planet  our first test flight is a go  [Music]  let's get everyone home good luck  captaining  roger that  [Applause]  there's  [Music]  just a massive robot  [Music]  that was utterly terrifying and i regret  having joined  you right here  [Music]  i can provide sleep sounds if you like i  have several options summer night ocean  paradise whale calls no no white noise  is fine very well goodnight socks good  night buzz  flight recorders are on  t minus five  four  three  two  one  zero  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  we'd like  is  [Music]  [Music]  to infinity and  [Music]  bye